my company has a 401k type plan they
decided to cancel it and actually handed
me everything that I contributed this
morning and I was wondering uh what I
should do with that money I'm on step
two I recently just started the plan a
friend recommended it to me awesome how
much is it uh so it's a it was a 20
every $20 you put in they only put in 10
so uh until I got my debts paid I was
only putting in about 40 bucks a week so
it's uh only
$800 okay and what's your Deb
did they keep their match did they just
keep their money so it was a it's like
this deal where until 15 years you're
not 100% invested and I was
only 15
years yeah and you're still with this
company yeah you work for the
mob uh well I'm only about a year in
with this company I'm I'm 20 years old
yeah dude you're young enough that you
don't realize that they are taking so
much advantage of you